foreign
[Applause]
I'll see you soon little brother I know
that we are all going to die May there
be Justice
killed in clashes with security forces
at least four of the victims were
children
prosecutors say it is likely that most
of the demonstrators were killed by
gunfire
in the region of ayakucha the army
claims protesters attacked them with
blunt objects after weeks of protests
the government declared a nationwide
state of emergency allowing the Army to
support the police a mistake critics say
opening the door to the military
increased the number of deaths and
attentions everything doubled which
shows once again the danger of using the
military to control internal order human
rights groups say most of the deaths of
the demonstrators were caused by an
excessive use of force by police and the
military violating human rights
standards
the inter-american commission for human
rights in Peru is investigating alleged
violations
one of the first cities where protesters
demanded new general elections hundreds
of civilians and police officers were
injured in the clashes officer Luis
Rowley says protesters attacked his unit
with a grenade injuring 15 SWAT team
members
the crowd threw an object my partner
shouted grenades I tried to see where
but it exploded and we all fell on the
ground
another officer Luis Camacho said the
aftermath from the force of the
explosion left him numb that's when he
says a mob went after him
they kicked and hit me with rocks I
tried to cover my head and face with my
helmet until they took it off and hit me
as hundreds of people mourn the deaths
of their loved ones president Dina
boluarte has called for an investigation
but many peruvians are Furious saying
she is responsible for this deadly
political and social crisis